foreign
[Music]
with a cape on a no-hitter neck For the
Love of Edna Mode that thing's gonna fly
off at the first opportunity
generating sounds without the lungs I
want a colossal donut just like the one
on the sign
nuts that's false advertising to be fair
there's no picture a price next to the
Colossal donut sign so this is only
false advertising in the sense that it
hasn't been advertised at all
astronomers from Dakota law stock have
just reported an ionic disturbance in
the vicinity of the Van Allen belt
scientific jargon news position also
trying to preemptively explain how giant
mascots could have possibly come to life
as if this is the most unbelievable
thing I've seen happen in this show
parallel Halloween universe or otherwise
Rosary that looks less like leg attire
and more like face condoms
batmaning the giant donut on your first
try I feel like it just invented a
euphemism for something but I have no
idea what quick Robin to the comments I
got your donut Lord man and what are you
gonna do about it
this lightning strike has some
outstanding karmic timing but how does
lard lad remember events that happened
before lightning gifted him with
sentience
but how is it making this noise did the
lightning also Grant the gift of
internal organs and vocal cords the
supernatural lightning strike seems
oddly specific
Marge leaves with this instead of the
more confounding question how did you
get the giant donut through the house
and into the living room what that's not
ridiculous enough for you you want a
punch line too well I do not believe
this half-baked concede needs further
disproving
[Laughter]
the giant Timo Shanter had a slinging
along the building with such Menace I
could do a whole video of background
jokes and removals for this show I mean
I won't because I'm lazy but I can still
take a Sit off for this one fine the
magic woo-woo lightning storm
Frankenstein all the mascots to life but
how did it know to give this Magic
Carpet the ability to fly been reading a
lot of Aladdin have we Mr Magic
lightning storm from space you're
telling me Channel 6 had enough money to
build a giant 3D rendering of Kent
Brockman and embedded in a billboard not
only that they painted and finished the
parts that were hidden inside the
billboard show doesn't know how to local
news budget correctly
[Music]
[Applause]
shells on the floor clean that shop
s at Texas Roadhouse he came to life
good for him Easter sermons that
billboard had legs too
thing every political party ever says
about the other political party somehow
makes it into the script hey what's that
in his footprint whatever it is whoever
put it there made the interesting choice
of writing it in reverse so that it
would read properly in the event that
the mascot came to life and needed to
imprint a clue on someone's lawn
advertising is a funny thing if people
stop paying attention to it pretty soon
it goes away the unskippable ads on this
very video would beg to differ like that
old woman who couldn't find the beef
disrespecting Clara Peller that's right
didn't even have to Google it that piece
of information was just hanging out in
my brain taking up space that could have
been filled with an inspirational quote
the quadratic equation or a recipe for a
good lasagna
sounds about right
[Music]
just died because everyone stopped
looking at them causing them to lose
their Brand Power if you will but that
means lightning didn't just bring them
to life it also imbued them with a power
source directly linked to their core
function as an advertisement Why would a
freak Storm from space do that why do I
keep questioning the logic of a 30 year
old fictional storm and a beloved
cartoon I don't know maybe I was struck
by space lightning and given an oddly
specific purpose too Pro tip uh don't
think about the amount of slobber that
must be gathering at the base of these
helmets I said don't think about it
because the next advertisement you see
could destroy your house and eat your
family we'll be right back funny joke
except I paid for streaming with no ads
so joke's on you suckers unless it's one
of those things where the streamer
somehow doesn't count promos for its own
content as ads streamers
Valley cat trauma like this isn't real
it's a fallacy also that first we hit
Bart Square between the eyes so this is
a misplaced bruise boner at best
Willie's rake has five prongs and yet
Bart only has four scrapes and no that
doesn't mean I want to see more chest
wounds in a 10 year old I just want the
existing ones to be accurate
[Music]
but he got me with hedge clippers did it
happen in the last three seconds because
your hairpiece seem to have waited to
fall off until you shared this reveal
whichever the fundamental forces of
nature that are being neglected allowing
Milhouse's glasses to stay on his head
remember class the worst you do on the
standardized test the more funding the
school gets so don't knock yourselves
out
but also
can you handle the live one saying this
to a child
let me die in this classroom didn't
these kids see him get put on the card
and covered up why is shock oh just get
it out of here
not into the kindergarten
[Laughter]
it all started on the 13th Hour of the
13th day of the 13th month
we were there to discuss the misprinted
calendar as the school had purchased it
took you until the middle of March to
notice the calendars have been
misprinted also having a PTA meeting on
a Friday night also also why are they
meeting at night when you said it was
the 13th Hour why is it dark at 1pm
to be fair this is a terrible place to
practice your back piping having said
that there's really no good place to
practice your back piping other than the
vacuum of space where they can't be
heard
will we please Mr Van Houten has a floor
this is just ridiculous a man's on fire
if you don't deal with it he'll ruin the
floor and that chair and worst of all
you'll have to wait until you've hired a
new groundskeeper to get any of it fixed
[Music]
with your children's blood generating
sounds without the lungs larynx or vocal
folds also fire that's hot enough to
completely disintegrate All Flesh but
somehow still leaves remnants of cloth
Simpsons really did suck back in the
early years huh all right I ain't gonna
get them skeleton power Chief Wiggum
would be excellent at TV since and
honestly I always thought it would have
been Lisa using 10 coffee mugs and two
teacups instead of just refilling them
it's almost like they only did it for
visual representation of how much
caffeine they're drinking
this wouldn't even work in the real
world let alone a dream world I mean if
there were psychotic half man half
mowers in the real world look there's a
lot we don't know about the universe yet
I'm all for the t2 homage but if Willie
can turn into an elephant tank or
missile why couldn't he turn into a fly
or water or wait a tank was the perfect
choice why didn't that work Billy's gone
for good premature celebration hope you
get reincarnated as someone who can stay
awake for 15 minutes it's been less than
two minutes since Bart fell asleep don't
you bring your Inception into
my Simpsons logic I won't stand for it
okay so if I assumed H equals eight then
R cubed would probably be what 18 times
18 times 18 10 times e then times wait
unless he is actually standing for three
oh oh is is O A standing for zero does
that mean the vignette title is actually
zero I was told there would be no math
better right just went out in the closet
sorry Dad this is our spot it'll be
expressed as such in a moment but this
is a dumbass place to hide from visitors
considering it's one of the few spaces
guaranteed to be success when you have a
guest over I get Homer or Bart being
this dumb but Lisa should know better
also expecting me to believe that two
siblings would agree to share a hiding
spot
expecting me to believe that a cat and
dog would agree to share a hiding spot
also expandable two-dimensional pets
under this wet wolf I hate that this is
probably exactly how Selma makes her
meatloaf
time
hey you can just suck them out escar
gross what's going on here I'm so bulgy
fun concept and all but does this mean
The Simpsons crew know they're only
two-dimensional there have been entire
episodes about Homer being overweight
and so many moments of things being in
Marge's hair if they were truly 2D
nothing would work unlike this premise
which is hilarious despite it not
working and now I've slipped into an
alternate Dimension where I can't decide
if I'm removing a sin or adding a sin
well is that tree said to The Lumberjack
I'm stumped what a dumb joke the tree
didn't say anything to The Lumberjack
the tree had been chopped down and now
lay dead on the forest soil this
hexadecimal run apparently translates to
Frank rules which indicates to me that
Frank had something to do with creating
this universe and the fact that we never
get to see an episode of him plotting to
do this is a sin I feel like I'm wasting
a fortune just standing here actually if
you're just standing there it costs less
it's all the moving that really drives
the price up on that Circa 1995 3D
rendering budget I wish I read that book
by that wheelchair guy I don't remember
Ironside having much to say about black
holes and parallel Dimensions that
doesn't I'm going in nobody thought to
ask Bart about what he was doing when he
disappeared to find this length of rope
that every household apparently has and
then started to Anchor it to Something
in the living room
Mark seems concerned but apparently not
quite concerned enough to just yank him
back in by the Rope he's tied to
crack generating sounds with healthy
lungs larynx vocal folds or nose there
is no way Homer could hit this dumpster
from that angle without going through
part of that building like If You're
Gonna Play in the physics of the real
world we're going to send you based on
the physics of the real world you
brought this on yourself
erotic cakes I was tempted to sin the
missed opportunity of experiencing an
entire episode of a beloved animated
character dealing with in the real world
but Homer ending up in an erotic Cake
Shop is so perfect I can't bring
myself to do it so you Space Jam
for wasting a similar opportunity
fight is on fire
[Music]
my name is Cecil I'll sell you gas or
diesel cars on my lot some of them knew
some of them not
[Music]
are you gonna probe us why does everyone
always assume that what am I doing am I
harvesting farts how much can I learn
from an ass
y'all want to see a dead body Mom okay
Martin died at school today I think you
confused me with someone who gives a
shot
denim haircut
backpacks backpacks come get your
backpack boots and pants and boots and
pants
[Music]
[Applause]
I don't like sand it's coarse rough and
irritating when it gets everywhere
erotic cakes to be fair this one does
have nuts
[Music]
getting fun